breaking tonight president biden says he
thinks states
should pause their reopening efforts as
he worries about a resurgence of the
coronavirus
the president is urging governments
state governments local governments to
reinstate
mandatory mask rules his cdc director
today
even more blunt warning of what she
calls impending doom
if the country reopens too quickly we
have fox team coverage rich edson is at
the state department with skepticism
over the coming who report on the virus
origins in china
but we begin with correspondent kevin
cork and the growing concern
over a coveted resurgence good evening
kevin evening brett cdc director dr
michelle walinski expressing deep
concern as you point out tonight
that the u.s could very soon bear
witness to a fourth coveted surge
even as the country has averaged some
2.7 million vaccinations over the past
week still the numbers
are daunting in recent days the u.s
surpassing 30 million cases
with the seven day average bread up 10
percent as we're now averaging about a
thousand deaths per day
i'm going to pause here i'm going to
lose the script
and i'm going to reflect on the
recurring feeling i have of impending
view
we have so much to look forward to so
much promise and potential of where we
are and so much reason for hope but
right now i'm scared
right now i am scared says wolinski she
also added that the trajectory of the
pandemic in the u.s
looks similar to other european
countries like germany and france where
there is a
worrying spike in cases which is all the
more reason says the white house to
wear a mask i'm reiterating my call for
every governor
mayor and local leader to maintain and
reinstate the mass mandate
please this is not politics
reinstate the mandate if you let it down
white house also promising to ensure
that there will be a vaccine available
site within five miles of
90 percent of all americans by the 19th
of april that is a scan three weeks from
today
cdc director by the way also mentioned
that the recent increase in trap could
be due to
travel that's a spike in cases although
it's important to point out brett in
some places like texas for example
they've actually seen a decrease in
cases over the past 17 days we just read
that from texas governor
greg abbott brett kevin thank you